[Music]
hello everyone I'm Zoran T and today I'm
joined by Dan Hynes hey how you doing
good thank you Dan who is joining me
today to talk about alone in the dark
illumination which I recently got
hands-on with during its closed beta
period now learning the dark is a series
of horror games for those who do not
know and this will be a continuation of
that it will be still published by Atari
but this time around it's being
developed by someone new so this is as
you can see the camera angle first of
all is different this looks like a third
person shooter rather than your typical
survival horror game yeah I mean like
they still are calling it a survival
horror game so I was quite enthusiastic
to get hands-on with it and I entered
the single-player mode and as you can
see you've got like your objective in
the top left corner you've got your
health you got your stats and you're
toting a submachine gun as you go along
and you know what things that you can
interact with it all highlighted which
kind of reminded me a little bit of left
4 dead it looks very much like that
you've also got a flashlight at the end
of the gun as well so you're not exactly
in the dark but you are very much alone
it's gonna play out but because
objectives are highlighted in bright
orange as you can see the whole thing
kind of feels really like you're just
constantly running towards an objective
can I just say is that a flamethrower
yes that's a flamethrower so your gun
actually has a flamethrower on it oh and
you don't need to switch to the flames
right ok flashlight equipped gun that
also has a flamethrower on it because
these monsters I'm shooting here you can
only kill them when they're in the light
right if you shoot them while they're in
the dark they won't go down but you can
kill them any time using a flamethrower
oh and I'm guessing the reason for that
is because of the flames produce light
although that can be said for your
flashlight so I'm not really sure about
the consistency it's not like Alan Wake
where you know you couldn't you have to
damage them by running your flashlight
on them first first okay yeah I
definitely get that vibe although
there's much less horror then there is
there was an Alan Wake and like I don't
say I'm scared right now no I didn't get
that vibe at all although they do do
things like they'll throw a random bit
of decor like that to kind of throw you
off I'm not really sure what purpose
that serves you can't interact with it
he doesn't really contribute much and
that
of text you saw at the very beginning
was the only means of which they used to
describe the story right and this is
also a cooperative game as well even
though we're not currently playing in
cooperative mode right no but that's the
thing like this map that I was on felt
like it was pulled out of a multiplayer
setting and you were just kind of like
it was really big really empty and
there's nothing you could do except like
go around flicking on these lights that
you see on the wall all lighting up
barrels to produce sources of light in
which you control monsters into and
these monsters just came out like wave
after wave after wave and at the end of
each map you go towards a safe room
which is what I'm what I'm next to now
and you open the door and like go into
it which i think is kind of strange
because you know why is this guy come
into this town only to try and escape
straight away it's it's it's video games
you know they make perfect sense now and
although there are different types of
monsters like the one like what's
happened here is I once just blown up
and thrown me look at me through the
doors of it so I got a bit stuck but
yeah you just go from one end to the
other and complete your objective and
that's it okay so not looking that good
for alone in the dark illumination no I
was quite disappointed to be honest
because I was expecting more from walls
of what called itself a survival horror
game
you